chaque 9 novembre nous commémorons la
disparition du général de Gaulle pour
tous les Français c'est évidemment
l'homme du 18 juin mais c'est aussi
celui qui sauva l'honneur et la
souveraineté de notre pays il est celui
qui a remis le pays sur la voie de la
prospérité industrielle il est aussi
l'homme de la stabilité de nos
institutions par l'instauration de la
Cinquième République pour toutes ces
raisons beaucoup de familles politiques
voudraient s'approprier la figure du
général de Gaulle et son héritage chaque
français fut et ou sera gaulliste disait
le Général de Gaulle il parlait
évidemment des français et non pas des
partis politiques car il n'est qu'un
mouvement qui s'inscrit depuis le
premier jour dans l'héritage gaulliste
c'est le nôtre ce sont les républicains
le Front national devenu le
rassemblement national s'est construit
contre le général de Gaulle
Emmanuel Macron s'est construit à
l'ombre de François Hollande lui-même
héritier de François Mitterrand qui a
mené toute sa carrière politique contre
le général de Gaulle il en fut un
opposant notoire l'histoire des parties
ne se réécrit pas chaque famille
politique à son histoire avec les
républicains les Français ont la liberté
d'écrire leur avenir avec les valeurs
gaullistes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]